is the reason why Zimbabwean culture is
I'm completely you have to be able to
speak to your child you can't silence
your children you guys do this all the
time oh Mom I'm going through this shush
oh I'm getting before you can't take
boys
with a bunch of wine or where it's like
this problem that problem that they used
to live through plague like they used to
live through real problem now we have
all this trauma this mental unstability
I'm not talking about you personally but
it's like it's like and you don't
deserve an explanation from your parents
forever
you don't deserve anything I do but the
world doesn't owe you the world
owns me
yes it does yes it does